[Music]
find yourself bored you're probably
listening to the same boring podcast I
am doing that well you should try new
Lifeline luxury wait a second Lifeline
luxury our podcast is called Lifeline I
know but this is different it's not just
the regular run-of-the-mill podcast with
us two brothers it's more and it's on
patreon but that must cost a fortune to
subscribe to nope it only costs five
dollars if you act now on patreon.com
Lifeline luxury
so for only five dollars you can listen
to our great podcast that's exactly what
I'm saying what do you get an extra
episode a month or nope at least two
depending on our schedule wow that's
twice as many as I thought could be
three could be four could be a hundred
it won't be it'll probably just be two
but how does it differ from Lifeline our
normal podcast well there's no video
submissions it's just us bantering as
brothers just me and you yep
ah
give it a listen and we promise it won't
be bad and dumb like other people's
podcasts so subscribe now patreon.com
Lifeline luxury
[Music]
foreign
would you lookie lookie there dude I
would look you look you there and I did
look I look you there you know
um I've had so much mucus the past few
days I don't
boo it's just crazy dude it's like
enough's enough mucus hey come on chess
let's get it going first bit the worst
bit it's not even a bit dude it's just
like crazy like if it was a bit I know
the worst bit ever dude
all right I know what's coming but I
look all right huh you look all right
yeah 43 [__] killing it oops bleep
that out you know you're 43 yeah
only for a little bit dude I lose that's
one year
um yeah you ever get like that like I
wasn't sick
I think maybe two days I was like
on like under the weather-ish
but like not sick and then just mucus
just for days and days if it involves
from the neck up it's happened to me
before that's how bad my decapitation
sinuses wow and
and what not
you know yeah
um no my sinuses my like my ear really
throat I've had it yeah oh yeah you've
had ear infections
throat infections remember I mean you
know the story yeah you've told it on
this one too okay well relax I'm not
gonna tell it again
I'm reminding you because often I tell
stories two three times on a podcast you
know I just now
this is exactly about what you're saying
you're sorry to cut you off but
I just now have begun to
get to the point where I'm like oh God
uh but the fact remains uh I contain
multitudes so I'm really never gonna
bore anybody even if I tell the same
story it's going to be like whereas
before I might have been like you know
what I mean okay Martin Lawrence
look at the Cow but I wish dude Martin
Lawrence do we talk about Martin
Lawrence being in a drama we did we knew
it for your multitudes right so it's
okay I contain multitudes so when I talk
about it uh uh this time maybe it'll be
a little bit different so what's up with
you man
I get hot you want to talk about mucus
and how you have a lot of it I just I'll
just be like oh okay I'm 130 degrees
inside really yeah all the time no no
not all the time do you like to have the
air on I here's why it sucks I hate
having the air on but I reach but I need
it on preach your house is like a hot
house you can only grow orchids inside
your house dude I think that once I get
once we get older you know that Kristen
and I are gonna actually have to have
different temperatures in different
rooms what's what's the deal I like it
four
okay true 74. I feel like you like it
way hotter than well you have to put it
hotter to get the 74 and have it right
see this is the where we describe okay
keep going
um she likes it 70.
it is it is different one degree is
different well let's start here she's
absolutely correct to want to understand
that's what you think but one degree is
a huge difference one degree they should
do degrees a little bit less of a
difference than they are wow dude that
is so dumb
that's so dumb you have to think about
it for a while they realize the depths
of how dumb one degree difference is too
much of a difference for it to be one
degree it should be that should be two
degrees well you know like one degree
should be two half of a degree is
something you know that right yeah but
not on thermostats and stuff it's not
the new ones is that true yeah the new
ones just they're all digital she dreams
in digital wow okay she dreams in
digital do I even know that what is that
what do you do dreams in digital yeah
what is it it's called two dreams and
digital the song
well dude I you do know it but I I think
that degree should be spaced out a
little bit better that's what I think
and what do you mean a half of a degree
is something I have anything is
something right exactly so
in terms of the measurement who cares if
you have to say half or a whole I get
what you're saying though about setting
the 30s exactly like it's not these
anymore where you can do it like that
you know now it's just like oh you plug
in You Know It's All Digital so it's
like
yeah okay but we're great boys today
we're both wearing gray I was wearing
purple but uh uh I got a little
you actually I've been a little hot I
was gonna tell you when I came in you
you were dressed more normal than normal
than your normal
and then you took what you had off and
you put on a shirt that's ripped looks
like a bobcat was a attack cover
attacked by Bobcat oh I'm glad I changed
there's holes in this one yeah yeah
there's so many holes in this shirt
there's some holes in this shirt
armpit
lost your mind oh okay yeah so I see I
was at a place today
boring not yet this is the beginning
I don't like to say specific locations
when people show up okay okay what kind
of places are my spots you could
describe it okay without giving away the
entire Cafe okay okay uh I was there and
there was a really really really
beautiful woman and a guy that was a
five
discuss together
discuss
uh
they like each other they love each
other probably hopefully okay sounds
like you have stuff to say about it
because I don't have anything to say
about it could be money right
I suppose it could be money who has the
money in that situation well in any
situation it's the one who is less
objectively appealing there you go
so I didn't you know I didn't say it but
I'm I'm sure I agree with you and so I
just think that that guy was probably
you know what do you think about that
discuss I don't think anything about it
what do you think about see them it's
not interesting these things happen it
also happens the other way around what
like mandate women who are money who
have money
well we don't know it's money what we
don't know it's money I'm saying often I
see a guy who I'm like damn out I'm
gonna touch him and it sizzles yeah he's
hot and the woman's just like whatever
and you're saying about him and you're
saying it's maybe money no I'm not
saying that you that happens very very
way that happens way less than the
opposite that's why I'm not saying I
mean this is the reason because of this
it makes the world go around but you're
not even saying makes a world go around
all you're saying is that you think that
couple that guy's rich and that's the
only reason that woman's with him that's
all you're saying over he's got racks
probably
and then she's got you know looks and I
see many times the other way too though
like shooting women because of women
actual loser dudes who are not even
physically attractive who happen to have
something about them that this guy
didn't I don't think I saw him and we I
saw the way he was moving around
describe him
regular looking uh that's doing this a
lot doing this a lot
falling asleep no just like not
impressed oh well that'll do it
sometimes when someone's like I'm not
impressed that'll make someone to be
secure want to impress them you know
maybe he's got like some Voodoo going on
maybe but I didn't think or something so
Charisma regular body
uh not good not good like you know
didn't work out probably looked like he
had money probably you're jealous
so I wouldn't say that because I have a
beautiful woman and she's hotter than me
and I like that okay well then great so
it's all settled so you basically saw
yourself in that guy
remember okay no no no no Kristen loves
me for me for 100 you know that wow a
dog took a dump in here yeah a dog took
a dump in here and he cleaned it up it's
all good dogs got tummy problems because
dog dump over here too so there was any
weight so my point is
a lot of times women do it with guys for
money but guys don't normally usually do
it with women for money
okay well why are you saying discuss
when really all you wanted to do is say
that over and over and over and over and
over again my point is do you think
that's okay discuss
of course it's okay to date somebody for
no matter what yeah well there you go
and that's what and that's who said it
Matt said it listen it's June 4th you
know what that means episode 60 but you
know what that means even more so sign
up for Lifeline luxury and it would be
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and that's
what you do right now you can get that
lifelong luxury and you can see the
first episode of Lifeline Library which
is no videos it's just us being brothers
and banterin and it's uh over 30 minute
episode and we're doing it at least
twice a week and that's Lifeline luxury
that's what it is
sorry twice a month it's unbelievable
right all right so I said twice a week
meant twice a month you can cut it out
or we could just let it roll babies
um so you can do that twice a month at
least twice a month but uh lifetime
luxury support the patreon it's also
really cool keeps this show going
um I'm on tour chrisley.com I'll be in
Tucson soon I'll be in Colorado soon so
go hit it up and uh if you got a
question click the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com or leave us a message on a
hotline at
213-973-8095 or if you want a one-on-one
advice session with Matt over here
matalia.com and uh you can make uh make
advice uh sessions with him or and you
can get the new Lifeline large Lifeline
merch at lifetime merch.com uh it's a
purple pimp and stuff and the hoodies
and it's all good I had some really
interesting sessions my last day every
once in a while I'll have like an
entirely full day from 1 30 to whatever
six and I'll tell you what yeah it wears
me down I I bet it does giving so much
of myself all right so that's not what I
thought you were gonna say what did you
think I thought you're gonna say it just
it took the focus is hard because it is
hard the focus is easy I'm impressive in
that way okay so you're so what's hard
is yeah I give and I give and I give and
at the end of the day I still have a lot
left because I have a lot to give but
it's less so I'm all worn down I'm woozy
I'm just like oh okay at six o'clock I'm
definitely do Japanese again so I'm
usually I'm at the end I'm like
no no no that's not what I was saying
but I get what you're saying but that's
not what it was
um um
rate my hair
[Laughter]
rate it though uh
seven what what did you want me to say
do you really think it's a seven I mean
it usually is like an eight I think
today's the same oh you think it's worse
than normal I do what I I mean I totally
disagree that's why I'm asking to rate
it it looks too clean or something
you're asking the wrong guy obviously
straighten my hair Marco
Antonio that's a seven he means seven
any any time that someone's like can you
step over I mean seven better than
normal right Anthony rate it
I give it a six oh Jesus Christ it's
worse than normal yeah there you go
there you go there you go I thought it
was literally better
let me see make it messy dude
just put your hand through it a little
bit there you go better that's better
yeah seven
that's a 7.8 right there oh wow one one
tussle he knows his so now what do you
think Decimal System uh it's now a six
he made it worse
can't make everyone happy then that's
what that's a lesson I tried and that is
the list yeah all right cool so look
let's get into it
let's do the first video all right come
on guys
listen to every episode this is the
first time I've had a good question for
you so it's regarding my living
situation pause it I just moved to the
South props to this guy for not rushing
it for just enjoying this enjoying the
process enjoying the show not rushing it
wants to be on the show doesn't want to
give a dumb question props to this guy
oh waiting it out that's what you meant
having a good uh question sucks you
should have waited but he thinks it's
good oh I will decide so go ahead you're
right England from Scotland I'm renting
a room in an elderly lady's house
there's another guy who rents in there
too but I stay in a room in the garden
she calls it a garden room I call it a
glorified shed
basically my question she doesn't
believe in locking the doors
which I think is kind of nice she
doesn't lock her front door back door my
room has no lock on it and it's on its
own in the garden so I'm in two minds
about it because on one hand I kind of
want to ask if I can have a lock
installed
because sometimes I'll leave you know
it's my room's on here I leave nice
stuff there if I don't want it stolen
don't need to explain it on the other
hand it's like Good Vibes hippie Vibes
you know yeah until you feel [__] gets
stolen you know like you can trust
people
and I just don't want to ruin that Vibe
I don't know what are you guys in
Scotland I'm in two months so thanks
okay so he's in South England well we
know what Matt thinks about that is it
is there a crime I think you better lock
the [__] up is what I think about that I
mean it's just to me look I'm American
it's so weird to think about not having
a lock but yeah uh
uh I you know I I don't think it's bad
to ask you pay rent you want your stuff
to be secure I get what he means though
he's like I don't want to like mess with
the Good Vibes that woman has lived her
life this way and it's like honoring
that to keep it lockless however
the lockless monster will get you one
day you know what I'm saying right yeah
I do know what you're saying it wasn't
necessarily executed so great but what I
said was great I said lockless and then
I slipped it right into the Loch Ness I
know what word play was word play yeah I
understand that but it wasn't like it
was pretty good great it was lockless
monster lockless monster is gonna get
you you're saying something one day to
Rob is [__] sometimes someday like
someone will enter your thing whether
it's a car house it doesn't matter if
you leave it online butthole this is in
America I don't know what it's like in
South England I have a pretty good idea
it says naughty naughty right yeah I
have a pretty good idea but um just ask
for a lock and say I think that's really
cool but like I actually have some
valuable stuff back here can I just have
a lock and then I'll not only will I
remove it when I go but I will repair
the door so it never looked like there
was a lock on it in the first place I
think it's a good thing to have the lock
but um I because if you really really
boil it down down a lot of Vibes are
nothing
lovers are nothing I don't I you know
what I think I would have agreed with
you maybe earlier in my life but I don't
agree with you now okay a good voice
because living with a good vibe is like
it's Irreplaceable there's nothing no
you better than that you can live with a
good vibe but a lock doesn't change that
Vibe is a Vibe is what you create in
your in your but it's her home and it
does for hers but he's he's being
onerous of that oh he's he's being on
he's honoring her vibe yes okay you
respect survive and honors her vibe and
doesn't know if it's okay okay to throw
a lock on that ass okay you know okay uh
I think it's okay to ask her if she says
no that's super weird uh but I guess she
does own the house but what Matt said is
you you'll take care of it when you
leave but you got valuable stuff there
right I mean look you probably got you
know
certain things that you don't want to
get taken and now especially since
you've been on this uh podcast people
saw your face and they're gonna see like
oh that's that guy they're gonna follow
you on problems
they're gonna kill the other guy that
stays there with you everyone and
they're gonna kill you and take all your
values there you go right so I would say
get a lock but I'm American I don't know
uh an alarm system get a tripwire dude
get one of those things in that movie
Entrapment where uh Catherine Zeta John
how crazy is that that everyone knows
that moment from a movie no one saw
so you know why you know why if you
bring up Catherine Jones or entrapment
all anyone that will ever remember or
think of is her butt missing the red
laser you know why
because it was in the trailer and the
trailer was everywhere but do you know
why even more
because that ass is featured do I don't
know why even more more than that yeah
no I don't know why because that was
Catherine Zeta Jones's moment in time
that was her moment where everyone was
weird
I know I know so like I know corny that
was when Catherine Zeta Jones I don't
even think the movie did that well but
maybe before that she was in Zorro right
I think then this was her holy [__]
she's gonna be a movie star thing how
weird is it that that was ever that
things were ever like that this is not
how it is anymore for actors or movies
for that matter it's so I've never even
saying it was better even though I know
this is neither better or worse though
this is just so different everything is
so crazy man wow so boring everything's
so crazy man no but I mean like you do
like even stand up it used to be about
getting an hour special and now you just
want to have a [__] 30 second clip go
viral like what the [__] dude it sucks
and I post [__] that like you know isn't
in my act like it's just like stuff that
happens off the cuff moments that I'm
not gonna put in my special or whatever
and sometimes people are like yeah this
is awesome and it's like just suck to me
I'm like it just happened it's like so
easy to do but it's just a promo for
people to come see my show it's easy for
you to do because you're a comedian it's
like
being like I don't know why everybody's
so obsessed with the way I hit a tennis
ball it's just like I'm just like
whatever yeah yeah cause you're the best
you know yeah thank you very much but I
feel like no no he's better at tennis
than you are a comedy don't get no I
don't know man but also but also uh
crowd work is a lot easier than people
think
that's what I'm saying okay sounds like
you're kind of Taken you're taken yeah
the conversation then you're just
ripping it right at towards you you know
what I mean crafting a great bit is
harder than material
okay okay about Kurt Cobain uh the guy
though culturally I can't speak to South
England even though I think there's
devious people waiting behind every Bush
to especially naughty things to you but
that's just my opinion maybe it's safe
but if it's at all like an area that is
normal which means that sometimes
there's crime just a little bit yeah get
a lock right right you know or ask ask
then if she says no get a lock no you
know what you should do because I'm sure
legally you have to allow your tenant to
put a lock on the door anywhere in the
first place for sure you should get it
say can I get a lock if she says no Then
without asking her hire a security guard
and have them sit outside of your door
and have her be like when she's like
what the hell is going on why do you
have a [__] guy ass huh because I had
the higher security guard because you
only have a lock right and then when she
says we can't do that you say security
escort her off the premises please yeah
or you could do that yep so next one
expensive but all right next one
hey Chris hey Matt just uh following up
from last week's video oh yeah uh thanks
for the advice you guys remember what it
was what was it he oopsie oh wow dude
Chris you know
[__] went all the way back to his
first home page on a website that
doesn't even exist anymore wow I mean
dude
so far back no I skipped ahead all right
so let's go what was it this is the guy
who uh his co-worker with uh Down
syndrome got his phone number and then
was like asking oh hell yeah dude how'd
it go did he take our advice
hey Chris hey Matt just uh following up
from last week's video uh thanks for the
advice you guys were funny and right
Matt you were correct I didn't I should
have over thought it I asked him to just
stop please and he said sorry didn't
mean to so we're all good into my mind
Chris could always start a family so
we'll see I'll see you in Hamilton in
October oh yeah don't stay the night
it's not safe and tier viewers uh send
more follow-ups we're all on this
journey together I want to see what
happens with everyone that's a good idea
that's a good idea he's he's right we do
like follow-ups I do like getting new
stuff and Fresh Faces but we do like
follow-ups especially with the
interesting one I'm not surprised the
advice I gave worked but what was his
query and what was my response but also
before we even get into that what was he
saying about how he might want to start
a family one day oh he said that to me
but what was the remind me I better I
bet it'll come he said I have a guy
who's got down syndrome that keeps
texting me every time I give him all
right of course and you said just ask
him not to yeah right right right right
which was I guess good advice but I had
good advice too and he didn't take him
we don't know if it would have worked
even better
yes I don't know what the family thing
was that he was I don't know either but
it's okay we can go back and look but
it's just uh yeah good I'm glad our
advice works and we're out here changing
lives I mean it was my advice but yeah
sure together we came to it together you
probably wouldn't have came up with your
advice if it wasn't for what I said you
know what people say a lot in the
private sessions well they say what's it
like with Christopher I'm doing this
because you give such good advice and
your brother is funny okay well that's
so that's not necessarily true and
people will I mean I am funny thank you
but people will say whatever they say
just to because they have you there and
they want to compliment you if I was on
the zoom they would it would be also if
I was on a zoom with them they would
compliment me and be like you know say
things
that I was smart too so
all right you guys think I'm smart
they'd be like yeah if you so you're
saying if you said do you guys think I'm
smart they would say yeah
that's true basically of anybody because
nobody wants to be rude to somebody they
don't really know that well a lot of
people are rude to me they don't even
really know me at all yeah yeah yeah
yeah anyway but uh yeah so that's good
so good great we helped them we helped
them and not only that we helped the
other guy we helped the other guy too
right boundaries we got to set
boundaries too yeah all right cool
boundaries are good boundaries are good
everybody yeah dude let's see the next
one so Matt what's up Chris this is your
boy Nick up to NorCal so much coke uh
before I get to my question I wanted to
say Vanderpump Rules funniest moment of
matalia is confused was the end of
episode two sexually transmitted demons
when the last thing the guy says at the
very end of the interview is what do you
what are you gonna do with this and then
the episode just ends and uh and Chris
the funniest moment of congratulations
was when you went to Michael Kane's
website oh dude and you went to his
photos page and there were only two
photos man
um even I know that love you guys uh
you're the [__] and my question is about
hair
so I think I got a pretty good head of
hair but I get bored with it just like
girls do I want to change it up do
something different so what do you guys
think about guys dying their hair oh
lighter darker and not just dyeing it
but like highlights Balayage all that
fancy stuff
uh I'm 41. I'm an Entertainer I play
piano's in the wine country here where
I'm at
uh so yeah you know what I feel like
Chris is gonna say that's a no-go but
I'm hoping for some support from Matt
maybe I know what the answer is I know
guys dying their hair and highlighting
it I know what the answer is do you guys
think blonde blonde be hyper blonde yeah
because blonde is the blonde parts of
this table here here's what I think
about dyeing your hair to the root not
like any of the tips sorry go ahead
that's okay if you're gonna dye your
hair you have to dye it hardcore One Way
agree you can't oh yeah because you want
it to be more the color you have totally
yeah it has to be like I'm talking about
you want to do pink do pink but like
there there can be no trick involved is
my thing
like I've never dyed my hair once you
mean no you're not trying to fool
anybody yes yeah yeah yeah you can dye
your hair any color you want just not
don't act like oh yeah no this is my
hair
all right
so like okay that and that's it that's
it you mean people need to see your hair
and know that you don't yes yeah that's
exactly what I mean yeah I agree I agree
uh but also on that frosted tips are an
absolute no-go yeah highlights are an
absolute no-go yeah no dye your entire
head of blanket it with a color
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do a Ultra
blonde
I think you look terrible I don't care
what anyone says or thinks I'm gonna
have it and I'm gonna have the dangly
earring and I'm gonna have even more
holes in my shirt when I do it and
everyone's gonna be like chasing me down
streets and I'm gonna be like no no no
no
please back away I know you're all
beautiful women and whatever okay most
is gonna be most beautiful women doing
it and where do you live that there's a
mostly beautiful uh L.A wherever I go
yeah no I don't know about that anyway
the point is people are chasing me
trying to see the style up close I don't
really find that and I'll be like I want
my space I want my space after people
you ever seen a beautiful woman run
after someone and I don't think I've
ever seen it remember when the guy when
our friend was like yeah I mean she
wants me to chase after her and I'm just
not the gonna go chase after her and
then 10 minutes
bro I couldn't remember that more yeah
so [__] and it was so [__] it was
on Hollywood Boulevard you know so
[__] he was like weaving between cars
yep he was like I'm not gonna run out to
that girl she wants me to then literally
and literally ran out a couple minutes
later he is running after her loved it
in my head it's a cut too yeah my
memories
so I think that yeah zero dye hair or
unless you know that it's died I would
dye my hair I've never done my hair I
would dye my hair if it was obvious that
I dyed my hair I I don't wanna like my
Beard's gray I don't wanna I want this
there's a few Grays coming in here I
don't like that it's different colors I
want it to be the same color but I'm not
gonna dye it that's just not who I am
you don't think a little bit of salt and
pepper in your hair looks cool no no you
misunderstood me oh I said it wrong I
want it to be all the same color meaning
there is salt and pepper here and not
here yeah I want salt and pepper here oh
oh yeah salt and pepper to you is the
same color yes yeah the same as beard as
tears yeah so I guess I wasn't right
what I was saying but you know what I
mean now okay I do now yeah all right
let's do another one then my contacts
are blurry great
blonde go hyper blonde hey Chris I'm
Matt my name is Libby I'm from Kansas
City and I'm having a problem with
someone at the gym uh it's happened like
multiple times it's a worker and I think
that she thinks that I'm somebody else
and I'm not trying to be mean or
anything uh every time she like so I'll
talk to her but every time she talks to
me she's venting about something about
her life or telling me something about
her life doesn't ask me anything about
me
um and I'm just going there to just work
out and I have like a limited amount of
time and leave yeah so how do I not talk
to her
with like now being mean thanks I'd love
any advice well wait it's really
interesting to me okay that people call
in with stuff like that why because
those
kinds of things not only do I feel like
I always know what to do in those
situations but I like doing it so what
what do you like doing I would say
something like
I'm sorry
do we know each other yeah you would in
like a serious way though not like in a
sarcastic yeah okay gotcha like because
I I don't remember you at all right
right you seem to
it seems like the way you're talking to
me that we know each other right
and then
it's not even about getting getting a
hint it's just like that solves the
problem right but what if she said oh no
but I just see at the gym here and you
know oh oh then then you just say yeah I
only have almost exactly what she said
okay I only have a limited amount of
time I don't really have the time to
talk here sorry oh a hundred percent
okay yeah yeah what would I do if
somebody came to me and kept talking I
probably would like it and write it out
yeah well you would become friends with
that person but yeah invite them over to
like Thanksgiving dinner you know so um
uh really weird though that well so she
started by saying she thinks that maybe
she thinks she's someone else
but I don't know she thinks the person
at the gym thinks she thinks she knows
her but she's mistaken yes that's giving
a lot of credit to this woman I think
yeah true I agree you know what I mean
but that just happened to me
really someone thought it was you really
huh
was it
was 10 minutes before
oh no someone saw you and thought yep
you were me hey how's it going uh good
to see you again okay okay okay okay
okay okay oh yeah yeah absolutely that's
so weird we don't look we don't look
anything alive no I mean you definitely
could tell we're brothers but we don't
look like that alike come on like not
like that yeah no we don't look like the
same person even remotely yeah well I
mean but people when I was younger
people used to do that yeah you yeah I
mean and then they would go like they
said go oh no no you know what it is no
no they wouldn't do that you know what
they you know what it is we seem alike
that's what it is I think we sound alike
we seem like what I said was we seem
alike and that's the best way to put it
right would you agree with that no I
wouldn't you don't think I'm saying
another thing okay so what else then I
think we have the same manner of
speaking because I mean we Cadence maybe
yeah Cadence uh but that even has that
too to a degree yeah it's just like it's
the habitual things in life the things
that we learn and we never never have to
relearn again yeah like the way we laugh
the way we say things right the timing
of things tense would you say we seem
alike you would say that I don't think
we seem alike at all honestly can I say
something okay I don't think that's what
happened this person yeah that you ran
into I think I know who it was
and they they knew it was you okay and
you just don't remember them probably
how do you know that because they texted
me they said Chris didn't recognize me
who's the person oh you can't we can't
say it obviously we can bleep it was it
a girl yeah it was a girl okay then
we're talking about the same person
obviously how do I know her because
you're friends with them she was here I
think she watched the show here before
[__] and it's not that big of a deal
you've probably seen her once okay so I
don't feel so bad no but she didn't
think that it was Matt
all right well now that that's settled
well that's [__] great dude wow so
now I just [__] should think somebody
me Crystal Lee is a dick ah well she
wouldn't be too far I'm really not
addicted no you're not there no you're
not no it's understandable and I'm sure
she [__] doesn't care yeah I'm sure
too yeah wow it's just so unsure I want
her to know that I appreciate her saying
hi
I will send her the timestamp of this
video okay there we go that's great
perfect awesome she seemed very sweet
honestly
I can't wait to figure out how I know
her but uh at the end after the show but
anyway uh all right cool let's do
another one then huh
oh hey man that's right asking well
what's up okay what's up
not on the phone you know using your
friends kid's name for your baby
is that weird question
he's changed based on
how well you know the person if they're
just like acquaintances if they're
friends you used to know
I don't know is that weird
because I really like the name
of one of our friends kids that we don't
talk to anymore but we are moving to the
same city that they live in
[Music]
so let me know what you think
but you don't talk to her anymore you
absolutely name your kid whatever you
want to name your kid why because here's
why it's a name that you're gonna have
to say yep more than any other name for
the rest of your life which is why I'm
gonna name my next kid Vin Diesel could
be Vin dieselia and you know I that'll
go well with my name because my name
is M diesel oh okay okay uh I I I don't
I I think I think you're right uh there
are names that have that are ruined for
me because of oh of course when you grow
up and you know somebody with that name
of course but what do you think of this
naming your uh kid
something like that
do you think you'd be able to ever get
over it
that you you know what I'm saying like
say oh yeah oh quickly yeah okay
immediately I think I bet within three
months all of the thoughts you had about
like all the association with the name
so terrible would be gone maybe
um
yeah I don't know uh I I think it's okay
but also it's definitely okay because
people name their kids literally their
own name
like George Foreman named any name all
those kids George correct that's so
[__] crazy he had a daughter and it
was Georgia right wow so you can do that
Gina or something yeah also they're
never gonna find out and even if they do
who gives a [__] yeah I remember when we
named Calvin Calvin uh our you know
matravenin his dad's name is Cal yeah
and uh and Calvin's middle name is
Matthew name after you but Matthew was
our next door neighbor and then his
dad's name is Cal oh they're like oh we
love that it's Calvin Matthew but it's
not because of them right I mean but you
know it's not you named cow your son
after the trevenons that's crazy I never
knew that I named him after calorie
because I love eating I love eating and
I love burning calories at the gym when
I do deadlifts right and I do do
deadlifts okay okay yeah I did
definitely the deadlift last time so
drawn Arnold Schwarzenegger though
really more than anything
and it did [__] scratch when I get it
when I go when I go today anyway dude so
that's what's up and I'm relaxed I'm
good I feel good dude okay okay my
contacts are [__] up all right all
right so let's get into it all right
what's up Chris and Matt Chris I saw you
recently in Cincinnati I think this was
the third time that I've seen you hell
yeah it was amazing thank you and also I
was the guy who walked up to David
Sullivan and told him that he is not fat
oh wow and I felt really stupid when I
watched the tour report video because
you there's a section of that video
where he's eating a bunch of junk food
and he's fat uh so I might retract that
statement there you go but he's not that
fat uh Matt you're awesome I love
listening to your advice uh there was
one episode where you talked about not
washing your hair and I tried it out and
it actually makes it feel a little bit
better I hear a heavy episode thanks for
that uh my question is we me and my wife
are moving soon
we are
gonna get rid of a lot of stuff in the
Box in the background my wife loves to
hold on to things oh boy so what could I
say to convince her to throw stuff away
what's the best way to do it she doesn't
really need the best way to do it I
don't know yeah go ahead thanks it is
the best way to do it you say sweetheart
or whatever you call her terminative
endearment yeah honey honey buns
whatever whatever he's got it he got it
so far I'm saying if you call it you can
go sometimes people are like fat fat
piece of [__] no that's not a name of
endearment it's not but they they do it
like it's ironic anyway all right so
you say
I'm assuming she she knows she needs to
throw some stuff away but probably
doesn't want to okay you say baby
go take the afternoon go do something
let me get rid of a bunch of [__] that
you don't need that's the number one
best way to do it because here's why and
I will tell you
she doesn't know what she's not gonna
miss yes she's holding on to [__] that
she doesn't need just because and she
doesn't realize she doesn't need it dude
when you know what when Kristen says do
you need this anymore do you want this
guess what I do I get mad
throw it away
you just wanted to throw it away throw
it away that's interesting because I
don't need it if I'm not [__] using
the most interesting thing you've ever
said on the show well no it's not dude I
think it is I say crazy interesting
things at this show and it's hard to
quantify which one's the best one but
dude but what that one is up there right
I have a little twist on on what you're
saying tell me if this is just as good
pretty [__] perfect but okay you do
that but you don't actually throw it
away you put it away and say
what do you think right and if they're
like it's great that's what I was
actually going to end up saying at the
end you didn't but I didn't though
because I thought you have it no but I
do agree with that because you don't
want to be like her to be like right
where's my [__] heirloom but I do
have a thing that you can do if that
does happen
so come up to me is my heirloom where
the [__] is my heirloom I have no idea
what happened to it
but it was in here it was not in it was
yeah but it wasn't part of the stuff
that I removed so it's somewhere you're
just gonna lie and then scene yes oh
okay so lie if you get called on it and
call that on there you go that's not
probably the best it's probably not but
also in the short term it will probably
help you my contacts are blurry I'm
pissed go ahead what's up with the
contacts they're just blurry they've
been blurry lately lately they just get
blurry is it allergies like I don't
think so the film over it the other day
I was at dinner and all of a sudden my
contact just goes like this
moved oh you might need an actual news
new uh prescription it might the curve
might be off a little bit you think yeah
our eyes change the more we correct our
eyes the worse they get I know that
because they work less and less hard I
know that just like people eh
I'm actually Evolution how about that
not Mexicans how's Evolution try
Evolution on precise
that's the worst thing to say survival
of the fittest why don't you try
survival of the fittest non-forcise the
most boring thing to say all right well
all right let's go next one
Chris and Matt I hope you're having no
idea today well this guy's voice is so
good
um and they're gonna roast my hair but
maybe you won't but Beach day here so
you know what I'm living life uh my
question is pause it this guy it's all
right you know has the greatest speaking
voice it's good ever heard in my life I
mean I would go that far but it's good
why are you jealous dude I'm not sure
it's great
I don't want his voice
that voice is crazy good dude you used
to be on the radio or something he's
handsome too though he could be on TV
even yeah okay I'm just going all right
okay I'm not saying he doesn't have a
good voice he does okay let's go where
do I handle people that come up and
say not his hand I'm praying for you
yeah or like I wanna I just want to let
you know that I am going to pray for you
and and hopefully God will do something
you know what I mean like fill in the
blank in those moments I don't want to
be rude and I'm like am I a terrible
person because in my in my mind I'm
thinking like I want to do a spin move
and be like well actually
I want to pray for you because it's like
why are you assuming that I need to be
prayed for you know maybe you need to be
prayed for am I a bad person for that I
don't know I don't think that I am but I
wonder what you what you all would do in
that situation here's the deal here's
the deal
That is rude it is to do that to someone
hey I'm praying for you when you know
they're not religious like yeah [__] off
dude they're doing that for them get the
[__] out of here of course they're being
so so yeah don't I don't do you're doing
this for you and that's annoying
yeah I I think that uh pray for I'm
praying for you the only response is oh
yeah do it or don't same thing happens
thank you dude Lord just don't waste
your time yeah don't waste your time I'm
all good man yeah I'm great
oh no don't waste your time
no hey dude oh hey I'm praying for you
oh dude no don't even do that man you
know why doesn't matter do it or don't
do it it's fine don't waste your time
it's all good man and it would be good
anyway I'm gonna go do my day it's gonna
be exactly how it was that'll be good
that would be good yup that would be
awesome
I would love that actually yeah that's
all good man I I mean I I guess
let's put this in the context of why are
people saying this to him
there are people in his life that want
him to be really crazy if they but he's
just getting that uh for at a
coincidence every like other day right
that's what I mean yeah like his family
is like I pray for you even though
you're going to hell if anyone leave
around that is rude yeah it's
presupposing so much I mean maybe he's
out there actually like just stabbing
people you know and people are like
robbing banks I'm praying for you dude
you don't know maybe he has a [__]
maybe he has stage four cancer and he
didn't well then it would make sense
yeah right but it wouldn't make sense
though because does it help
if you get a whole football stadium
of people and pray for the okay
if you had
somebody
in
the middle of a football field
right Chargers Stadium where they play
right so so far whatever it is
all right and you
had a whole football stadium full of
people
do you think that if the 60 000 of them
or whatever
prayed or thought very seriously about
something for that other person it has
any more of a chance to come true than
if they didn't
of course not
so that would be the test why don't we
do that yeah it sounds easy to do
it will be very hard but because here's
the thing in football stadiums you got
it full of people that want the same
thing they want the team to win but you
also have people that want the other
team to win the football stadium okay so
if you didn't let other fans in if you
only let the people in that wanted the
football team to win 14 to win do you
think that
do you think that team had a better
chance to win no I think no I think it
might because in the home field
advantages they're treat they're
cheering more yep you just said earlier
in the episode Vibe is nothing I know
that but but what I'm saying is
do you think that if they were all
cheering home field advantage that it
helps for the team
if they're going wild and cheering yes
that's something it's got different
field advantage but if they're not then
you don't if they're just thinking quiet
yeah that doesn't but the prayer isn't
what it is the Hope isn't what it is the
rooting isn't what it is it's the
atmosphere that is provided for the home
team so if they're not cheering if
they're just like this if they're just
like this it wouldn't oh you know what I
mean that wouldn't work no
okay everyone knows that all not at all
it wouldn't make a [__] difference
dude I don't even believe that you don't
know enough to ask the question I am
posing a question I am not saying I
believe one thing or another okay okay
well no I heard that if there's a
football team
a football stadium full of people
praying for something that has a better
chance of being of happening but a
Christian told me that I know okay let's
put it that way I know a Christian told
you that because it's not true
would say that okay
so I guess you could be another religion
but it's you're definitely some kind of
religion but a Christian you said that
right of course okay so next one
hello Christopher and Matthew only said
that because my boyfriend told me to
um has it gone to her head so my
question this time around is I've got a
girlfriend that I only see twice maybe
three times per year but um we're we've
gotten pretty close and
um see the thing is is that every time
we're together and we hang out
I noticed that she like takes little
things of mine without telling me
um normally she'll like ask like hey can
I use this can I use that can I borrow
this and I'm always like yes
but I also noticed that certain things
go missing like I noticed that she may
have I'm almost certain took like a
lotion of mine
um stuff like that so what should I
usually confront her about it oh yeah or
should I just let it go let me know any
advice is appreciated bye yeah but hold
on though hold on you don't know
if she took it or not she's almost
certain she said which is pretty close
to knowing but right Fair yeah okay but
she said there's other things too that
but she's asked for it
she said she asks for okay to borrow
some things whatever and that's fine but
she also thinks she's taking other
things oh yeah definitely don't accuse
her of it that's what I'm getting at
don't accuse yeah but you ask her
there's something
you only see her two three times a year
she how much often is she doing this
yeah right and how many things are you
missing here's my answer because it's
enough to bring it up that's [__]
she's a cut though yeah exactly that's
what I was gonna say if it's two three
times a year but she's taking things
every time this person sounds like she's
just not
like yeah she's got like some kind of
problem or something maybe which is a
reason to actually possibly even not
not bring it up but also never speak to
her anymore like if you're gonna not
bring it up I totally get it but that
means you should just
cut it all off yeah yeah but if you plan
on staying friends with this person you
absolutely should bring it up and say
Hey did you
take that lotion too I know I I know I
let you borrow but like unless it's just
lotion then it's like who cares right no
it's that makes it even that makes it
even worse I think someone took lotion
from me no look look listen okay I'm
listening if it was a valuable thing and
someone took it well that's it would
make more sense right if someone just
took a random thing from my home I'd
think they're like have some weird
obsession with me and they just want
something I owned okay well if it's a
valuable thing there's this is why it's
easier you just that person's not in my
life anymore
it's like a single white female
situation hey bro what are you doing bro
if you're so into my room but that
implies to me like some kind of dark
weird Obsession hey bro do you have some
dark weird Obsession what the [__]
going on this is my deodorant right you
took this [__] huh no let me explain
armpits that's the same one I use you
got different at CBS [__] what's the
deal
yeah this is like single white male
she's a female I'm saying if for me okay
yeah okay bro that's how I started oh
right yeah you made it to you um yeah I
don't know man
um I think that uh
that's pretty weird right it's extremely
weird but there are kleptos right like
what's her name Winona Ryder did it a
little bit yeah did she though or was
that meeting no she did yeah she did
yeah
yeah there are others too I actually
know people it must be a sexual thing
right stealing something I know people I
don't think so I really I know people
who shoplift still in their 40s what yep
it's crazy and what do they say about it
they just don't want to pay for things
that's is that a clip though though
because I thought a klepto does it
because of the sneakiness and the
sneakiness
to me saying just I just don't want to
pay for things he's like
uh
it's like in hindsight you're you're
creating the narrative okay it's
probably very fair anytime you have some
sort of obsession like that it's
secretly kinky though
why because secrets are kinky right did
Freud say that once
I think that's Freud
secrets that reminded me while I was
doing the golden hour and Brendan Shaw
was like some guy called in and he had
like a [__] t-rex with a Spider-Man
outfit on and it said spider rex on it
and Brennan says oh dude there's a t-rex
with the Spider-Man outfit on and I said
oh dude did you just figure that out by
looking at it
that reminded me of that cool
who's Brendan schaab you know who
Brendan is just kidding yeah all right
um so anyway dude my mucus is doing a
little better oh that's good why well I
wonder why probably because talking that
helps no it usually makes it worse for
me I know I know isn't that crazy
dude in that honestly crazy I really
like that guy's voice yeah well that's
uh yeah it's all good man dude um so
anyway let's do another one yeah sure
finally we're having a good time
oh boy
what's up Matt and Chris uh my name is
Ty and uh Chris I've been following you
since TMP so yeah despite the fact that
you do not know who I am I just want to
let you know that we are friends now I
know who you are dude and then Matt I've
booked a session with you before so
we've already kind of worked through
cool a little bit
my question is this I'm 29 years old so
as far as the internet's concerned I've
already got one foot in the grave yeah
and I'm starting to feel old a little
bit I'm starting to feel old because I'm
getting like cynical about yeah just
like generally popular media yeah sure
yeah and I wanted to know if any like if
either one of y'all experienced that
like Chris
for example [__] that's supposed to be
funny now yeah is just not funny okay
especially with like Tick Tock in like
people I don't know I just don't know
what people are [__] doing anymore
and then maybe a little more mad
oriented question would be like dude
movies are getting worse too it's like
I'm sorry but I'm I don't want to watch
any more [__] superheroes we do like
five Spider-Mans a year now yeah and we
[__] gotta watch you know Marvel DC I
don't give two shits stop making Star
Wars I'm out yeah there you go so I
guess my question is this is this just a
part of getting older yeah or am I a
[__] an [__] pretty much you're is
the question
you gotta wait you gotta wait you gotta
wait you you're you're definitely
getting older but you gotta just
keep that in check the fact that he's
asking the question is good right
because you don't want to become a
cynical [__] right no because it's
very easy to especially
I don't know man well it's natural to
get more and more cynical as you get
older and older because more [__]
happens to you and things generally in
life
things if you were to just take a random
occurrence in one's life and just like
like people do with a globe they spin it
and they put their finger on it all the
events of your life are on that globe
and you spin the globe and then you put
your finger down randomly chances are
that's going to be a bad thing really in
life because life is hard and life is
bad and except the moments that aren't
are so great but those are fewer and
further between you're saying that to
live is to find the meaning through
suffering I'm not saying that I'm saying
life is hard more often than it is easy
okay and so
the the more you live it makes total
sense to me that the longer you live the
more likely to be cynical right you get
because more life means more whatever
hardship heartache whatever the [__]
um so it makes sense but I do think that
it's something worth trying to keep in
check that cynicism yeah because frankly
here's something interesting nobody
likes a cynical piece of [__] yeah even
cynical pieces of [__] that's weird okay
so like it's like the one kind of way to
be that even other people like that
don't like
um so let's all try to Veer away from
cynical aging [__] territory
um yeah that being said
at various times culture uh uh can can
seem worse than ever you he brought up
movies but you could talk the same way
about music or whatever every generation
thinks that though exactly so
I think the healthy way to think about
it he brought up movies to stick with
movies for a while if you look through
past eras of movies
there were always
trends that died that seemed I'm sure at
the time like they would never go away
right you know uh and that's going to
happen to superhero movies in Marvel and
DC it just seems so difficult to believe
because we're so in the thick of it and
being bombarded all the time with
sequels and and and you know franchises
and and we're gonna be like you remember
the [__] remember like in the 2010 to
2020 2020 2030 dude there were so many
superhero movies we're gonna be like
that yeah for sure yeah and now it's
crazy well somebody like everything was
a sequel remember that you know it's
gonna be like that yeah remember like
nine different guys play Spider-Man yeah
that's a conversation I'm gonna have for
sure for sure yeah
um but it doesn't mean it's gonna get
better but remaining not saying now now
it's even worse we're gonna be saying
right but it doesn't mean that just
because it makes sense or it follows
that it's not going to get better we
have to follow believe that it's not
going to get better it could get better
so we should reserve some sort of belief
that it will because otherwise not
because it actually is probably going to
be better but because it would be a
miserable [__] existence if we all
sat around thinking well it's bad now
but it's going to be even worse everyone
would be jumping off a building right no
movies have never been worse though than
now
I I mean I agree I mean there was a
period in the early in the early Arts oh
yeah yeah that was just terrible a
little bit after the 90s yeah uh they
were pretty [__] terrible I mean 911
right people don't like it when I say
this but it's true dude 911 was like
the death now for for movies so many
things went wrong with uh Hollywood
movies after 9 11. really so it's just
another thing that why don't people like
when you say that because it seems
academic and it seems like sort of like
an esoteric thought but I just mean it
very literally like look at the movies
before 2000 uh September 11 2001 and
after that's true it just is it's so
Stark it's it's it's it's so clear to me
that even good filmmakers started making
bad movies after that it's really weird
you ever see a peacemaker with George
Clooney and that was before 9 11. yeah
yeah so it must be great no I'm just
kidding
um all right well yeah yeah I I don't uh
just keep it in check like which is what
I do anyway I I used to be more cynical
than I am now
um
it it's something you have to fight
against as you age because that [__] but
you're you know you're fighting a good
fight that's good
you are right that just asking the
question puts you in a better position
than most yeah because most people are
just like falling down their their
particular hole Yeah they don't even
think about the guy sounds like a smart
guy and he's pretty smart if he likes
TMP right nobody sounds like a smart guy
yeah um all right well that's about it
you know you can go get the merch at
lifelinemerch.com go get the tickets
I'll be in Tucson again I'll be in uh
Colorado I'll be in Nashville I'll be in
Canada christian.com I'll be in Las
Vegas
so uh that's what's up
also leave a comment it really helps
leave a comment algorithm and share this
with a friend send this YouTube to
someone else and be like yo check this
show out it's fun and subscribe to the
channel and
that last caller
his name's Ty he said it I wasn't gonna
say it right he booked a one-on-one
session with me yeah and I changed his
life his life is
exponentially better than it was before
this session and he made that
appointment on mattdelia.com okay as
easy as anything else okay so just go do
that and get your life very much the
most important thing today there is the
extra episode that came out go to
patreon.com Lifeline luxury uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury thank you
very much there you go
change hello hello
hello hello
[Music]